we are now going to play a little game
what do you get out there right now so
doc let ik um we are gonna play a game
called kiss and tell
when okay I'm gonna be showing you three
iconic olicity kisses and I want you to
tell us behind the scenes secrets about
what it was like to actually film them
that day what you remember about it so
this is not seven minutes this is not
seven minutes in heaven so we are gonna
start off with the first kiss right now
and this is all of our implicit E's very
first kiss oh wow look you can you can
talk you can tell us what you're
thinking say it's never gonna work out
between us say hi
[Music]
David Lee you look so young and look at
you
nugget don't ask me to say that I don't
[Music]
what do you remember most about Meredith
looks and she's like choose me pick me I
whenever there's like first kisses in TV
Meredith Grey yeah season three that was
in the hospital right yeah in the
hospital in the hallway okay yeah I
think because that was like our fur like
we were we were friends like we were
pretty good friends too but we were like
more work friends then than anything so
we showed me like yeah gonna be a good
day but it was more like that scene was
more for their characters was more
important about like it wasn't yeah I
mean a kiss was important for the story
and probably didn't know it was
happening like it's like I'll eat garlic
I don't remember
let's take a look at our second case
which is one of my favorites Oh weird
watching yourself oh I know I know I'm
sorry popper yeah I like tequila
let's go this next one this is Ivy town
yeah I miss Ivy town I honestly wish
that that was something that stayed
around longer right it's interesting
much if you ask an olicity fan they
would just want a whole season of it
just like sweatpants and makeup done at
home are you actually good at cooking
eggs no say you were able to really run
this look well you know when you like
makeup and then it's just moment yeah
with this little green hoodie
I remember the next thing when I put the
cooked in the baby how's your job good
good II used to running without chasing
ready I know I mean it'll never stay
back actually be happy yeah we were
happy
how sweet very sweet we just have one
more kiss for you and someone say it is
the most iconic Alaskans we're gonna
show you right now yeah so weird
oh yeah this one is complicated the
directors call this was the directors
call this was yeah so how did you even
begin well first of all we're lying down
that's how it was already a good day for
me anything horizontal I'm I I asked if
we could do this interview lying down
yeah oh yeah and then we humped
everybody loves humping
yeah he's virtually dry humping um but
that was like an iconic kiss but yes so
it was it was I just was always curious
like how did you this if you were laying
down and that was the director who was
like well did you see I was cut so we
were there and all of a sudden we were
lying down we just kind of came into
frame you think so if you want to
recreate that kiss for yourself I don't
think it's gonna be as romantic because
you gotta got to think about
[Music]